tine trois mois après la pose de la
première pierre le grand stade où se
déroulera le 12 juillet 98 la finale de
la coupe du monde de foot bal a enfin
trouvé son nom le stade de france les
concessionnaires souhaité une
appellation style elisa homme qui parle
aux étrangers les puristes souhaité le
baptiser du nom d'un sportif comme jules
rimet le fondateur français de la coupe
du monde
finalement vous voyez décision mi chèvre
mi chou reportage laurent frédéric
bollée claude sicard le jour se lève sur
le chantier de ce qu'on appelle encore
le grand stade
un jour pas comme les autres un jour de
baptême certes la maison de la radio n'a
rien d'une cathédrale et ces messieurs
ne sont pas des hommes d'église
il n'empêche qu'on est vraiment là pour
baptiser un bébé dans la recherche du
nom a nécessité des mois de réflexion et
la mise en place d'un comité
13h15 fin du suspense le 2 juillet 1998
la finale de la coupe du monde de
football aura lieu au stade de france
et bien voilà c'était pas compliqué
talent de transe juste le choix le plus
consensuel est le moins risqué
j'espérais que dans la seconde réunion à
paraître est peut-être des termes plus
novateurs je voudrais clore crevettes là
dessus j'ai plutôt échoué c'est pas
original mais c'est un nom qui va rester
dans l'histoire et qui est très beau je
suis ravi il aura donc fallu deux
réunions du comité de réflexion et une
consultation populaire sur les ondes de
france pour en arriver là le stade de
france qui en tout cas ne sera pas que
le stade du football on est cousin
germain avec le football simplement je
crois qu'on a
une chance extraordinaire c'est que le
rugby va finalement inauguré ce grand
stade avant la coupe du monde de
football en tout cas l'équipe de france
est prête à se rendre en bus ce sera
pour le tournoi des cinq nations 1998 si
le chantier avance comme prévu
puis il y aura donc du monde et
d'éventuels jeux olympiques le grand
stade a désormais un nom il reste à lui
construire un destin